álvarez knocked on the open door and
stepped into the office you asked for me
sir
dr. gears looked up from the files on
his desk fixing his gaze on the young
security guard yes I've been trying to
contact dr. clef all evening but he's
not answering his phone
I'd like you to locate him to make sure
he's all right and tell him I have
something urgent to discuss with him but
Sir it's um it's Friday night Alvarez
said suddenly uncomfortable if you'll
recall oh I see
it's is yes a decomps he's left
instructions that he's not to be
disturbed under any circumstances that's
right sir well I suppose things can wait
until tomorrow morning then very well
sir
Alvarez left the office doctor Alto
cliff sat in the dining room of his
sight 19 sweet the place was lavish by
any standards gold embossed wallpaper
ornate oak paneling 18th century
furniture the table set with priceless
China and the finest silver an antique
Ming vod's sat on a pedestal nearby
gleaming in the warm glow of the crystal
chandelier an original carvalho hung on
one wall a Vermeer on the other Barry
White played softly in the background
mmm
cliff exclaimed setting down his spoon
and wiping his mouth with his napkin the
fennel soup was exquisite d 120-130
really outdid himself tonight he
gestured to one of the several d-class
personnel in attendance more wine
D 238 97 right away dr. clef the man in
the orange jumpsuit said nervously
stepping up to the table and refilling
his glass with a particularly crisp
Chardonnay clef lifted the glass to his
mouth took a sip and signed with
satisfaction this is nice he said
smiling at his guests we should do this
more often
don't you agree across the table scp-173
stared back at him unmoving silent five
d-class personnel were positioned around
the living statue their eyes fixed on it
cold sweat dripping down their faces as
they struggled not to blink not to break
eye contact not even for a second a sick
man stood directly next to scp-173
trembling with terror as he lifted
spoonfuls of fennel soup into its face
smearing the contents where its mouth
should have been may I just say how
lovely you look tonight darling clef
said his eyes moving appreciatively over
the black evening dress covering the
statues curves the blonde lustrous hair
of the wig on its head its rouged stone
cheeks I was gonna wait until later but
seeing you like this
I just I look at me you have me babbling
like a schoolboy I don't know what it is
about you you've always had that effect
on me scp-173 looked on its stone
features blank impassive anyway clef
said I got you a little something to
show you how much I appreciate you being
here sharing this evening with me
clef reached into his pocket and took
out a small flat box handing it to d2 38
97 who was standing nearby the man took
the box and went around to the other
side of the table his heart rate rising
as he approached 173 open it darling
clef said
d2 38 97 opened the box revealing a gold
necklace inlaid with dozens of small
diamonds and it should be the right size
I had it made especially for you go
ahead put it on clef smiled D 238 97
removed the necklace from the box and
reluctantly tied it around 173 s neck
wincing as his fingers brushed against
the cold hard cement surface clef was
momentarily at a loss for words
it suits you to perfection he said at
last
god you're beautiful I feel like I never
want to take my eyes off you at that
precise moment can't get enough of your
love babe began to play clef felt his
heart flutter it's our song he breathed
as Barry White's rumbling voice filled
the air clef found himself staring into
173 Zaillian painted on eyes losing
himself in their depths you know he said
after a moment his voice now little more
than a husky whisper I'm suddenly not
hungry anymore
what do you say we retire for the night
cleff was lying in his ample band 173 at
his side the lush satin sheets in
disarray around them the d-class
personnel were standing in a circle
round the bed 10 pairs of eyes that had
not left the statue for the last two
hours I can't tell you how much these
little trysts of ours mean to me
cliff was murmuring 173 is a year
running site 19 all that responsibility
all those lives depending on me it's so
exhausting you're a miracle workers you
know you really his train of thought was
interrupted by a series of hushed
whispers two of the d-class personnel
seemed to be having an argument clef
cleared his throat loudly do you mind D
238 97 snapped to attention I'm sorry
sir
it's D 459 31 he hasn't slept in a
couple of days and he was starting to
nod off I told him he had to keep his
eyes open oh I see well actually that's
not necessary D 238 97 frown confused
but sir the statue I won't deny she can
be a feisty one
but with those Fiesta states of hers but
as long as I'm around she won't try
anything so there's no danger D 238 97
ask that's right no need to worry now if
that's all clef said I'd like to get
back to then why are we here D 238 97
nearly shouted in disbelief why did you
make us stay clef gave the man a strange
look the hint of an unhinged smile
playing on his features I just like it
when people watch
I would like to give a special thank you
Esmond Hoskins Andre Bashar
dr. mortis Cody tench pierce em Hamlin
sy7 actual
fidelia's
hyperbole
if you would like a personalized thank
you at the end of each of my videos on
some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you